نذهب الان الى غازي عنتاب مع عمر الحوراني
عمر حدث لنا المعلومات
والاخبار والمشاهدات لديك
نعم بدايه نتحدث عن استمرار في عمليه
انتشال الضحايا من تحت انقاض هذا المبنى
الذي نقف بجانبه هناك عمليات انقاذ تم
انقاذ انتشار العدد عدد من الاشخاص من تحت
هذه الانقاذ ونقلهم في سيارات
الاسعاف وايضا
العمليات مستمره يوجد هنا فرق
توجد هنا يعني سيارات اسعاف لنقل الضحايا
ان كانوا يعني من من تبقوا على قيد الحياه
او من فارقوا الحياه
وهناك عدد من الابنيه يعني وصلنا اليها
وكانت العمليات مستمره الا ان حجم المياه
هو كبير وعدد
الطوابق هو كبير لذلك يصعب بشكل يصعب يصعب
يعني انتشال الضحايا من تحت هذه الابنيه
وهذه الابنيه بحاجه الى معدات عملاقه لرفع
الارقام وانتشار الضحايا من تحت هذه من
تحت هذه الابنيه ما زالت ما زلنا نشاهد
الاهالي يجوبون الشوارع في سياراتهم يعني
يجدون ان من
الامور التي يتخذونها هو
يبقوا ضمن سياراتهم وايضا هناك عدد من
الاجراءات التي تم اتخاذها مثل الدخول الى
المساجد وسط استمرار في تساقط الامطار
نتحدث عن الامطار غزيره لم تتوقف حتى لم
تتوقف حتى الان منذ
الحدوث الزلزال وايضا الثلوج تغطي الاراضي
الارض كون المنطقه تعرضت ثلجيه خلال
الايام الماضيه وما زالت الثلوج يعني
موجوده وهذا الامر ساقم من معاناه
الاهالي هنا وما زالت معاناه مستمره وذلك
مع استمرار
هزات الارتداديه التي تحدث
والاخرى وهذه الهزات مستمره
الهزات الارتباديه
نعم نعم ونحن قبل دقائق شعرنا
ارتداديه لكنها لا تقارن بالاجزاء التي
حدثت بدايه وقد عايشنا هذه اللحظه وكانت
من اللحظات الصعبه التي عايشناها وكانت
استمرار استمرار للهجره لوقت كبير
نوعا ما قياسا بالحديث عن الجلاجل وايضا
ايضا كان حجم الاهتزاز
هذه اللحظات كان اهتزاز المباني بشكل كبير
وهرانا مثل ما هرع الكثيرون الى الطرق
والتابة كان
خروج من المنازل الناس لم ترتدي ثياب
تقييم من هذا البرد حيث ان البرد قارص
ودرجه الحراره متدنيه بشكل كبير
المحظوظ من الاهالي من كان لديه سياره
استقلها
كان هناك كثير من الاهالي كان في
المواطنين عمر
خاصه مع استمرار الهزات الاستداديه كما
تتحدث
الخيارات كانت كما الخيارات التي اخذتها
انا ذهبنا الى مناطق مفتوحه لا يوجد فيها
ابنيه بالقرب من حدائق على اطراف مدينه
غازي عنتاب صراحه كانت هي حاله كان هناك
حاله صدمه لا احد يعرف الى اين يتجه كان
هناك
يتجهون باتجاه
المركز المدينه واناس اخرون يتجهون خارج
هذه المنافق
البرد القارص ايضا هو من اشد المعضلات
تفضل انا يعني بما يخص البرد كانت شهاداتي
يعني شهاده يعني مشاهد مؤلمه لاطفال
يتجفون وخصوصا باللحظات الاولى قبل
استدراك الامر اخذ اخذ
وقت والصدمه اخذت وقت كبير حتى ان يعني
تمكنت من الاستيعاب وتوجهت وكان هناك
اعلان بعد نصف ساعه او اكثر من قبل
المساجد للتوجه للمساجد وهذا الامر يعني
خفف نوعا من الصدمه ومن معاناه الناس
وخصوصا ان درجه الحراره ما زالت متدنيه
سيارات الاسعاف يعني تجوب الشوارع وهذا
يشير الى انه هناك في انتشار للضحايا
وايضا نشاهد ايضا من القوات حتى
تواجد كثيف داخل المدينه لقوات من الجيش
وايضا يعملون على المساعده في انتشال
الضحايا نستطيع القول ان الان جل جهود
منصب على انتشال الضحايا والعالقين تحت
القرض وايضا هناك كمان شاهدنا ان هناك
سيارات ايضا تقوم بتوزيع الاغذيه وخصوصا
ان الكثير من اهالي ما زالوا في الطرقات
بسياراتهم يجوبون
الطرقات وذلك مع استمرار كما ذكرنا للهزات
الارتزاديه التي تستمر وهناك حديث عن ان
هذه الهزات قد قاربت لي المئه هزه
ارتداديه بعد العزه التي الكبرى التي حدثت
بدايه والتي خلفت هذا الدمار الواسع نتحدث
عن عن ابنيه باكملها سقطت
في عدد من الاحذيه وعدد من المدن التابعه
لهذه الولايه